all right julie here we go again this is
one of my favorite times of the year as
we anticipate what's going to happen why
should we be excited about this season
of big brother
well it's 16 brand new people so new
people to fall in love with new
showmances to see blossom new people to
root
maybe against you know a new like
favorite villain
and it's the 24th season
anything can happen i mean it took us 23
seasons to become like to have this
historic season last summer with the
cookout so who knows we always say
expect the unexpected and that is the
beauty of this show just for the record
buy a unanimous vote can you see xavier
xavier exactly
you want you got all nine votes
do you think the cookout forever changed
big brother and the people now are
really weary of everybody i think it did
i mean i think every season you watch
you know
good moves bad moves mistakes and what
gets people to the end so it's
definitely a model to go by now can you
all get along and find like a group of
six that will regardless of differences
in personalities stick to your word
you always say expect the unexpected
what
is going to be unexpected this year give
us a little hint i'm not asking you to
give it away but just give us a little
hint all right our challenges are next
level this season i mean and you're
gonna see that on premiere night it's a
90 minute premiere
and it's going to as soon as people get
in the house they're going to play new
challenges we've never had before and
then we're going to show you a crazy
first live eviction show it's going to
be
an eviction night like we've never had
before
i mean
people who were like real gamers you
know back in the day maybe season six
seven eight it's a whole new game yeah i
don't know if those people would do as
well today it's so much harder big
brother this year more than ever you
will forever be linked you're one of the
few people who will forever be linked
with a show you know that had a long run
what does big brother mean to you at
this point because it is
your baby
it's been a real journey you know when i
first started um 24 seasons ago
it was
reality tv wasn't what it was today
and i had a lot to learn along the way i
received a lot of criticism
and um a lot of it was you know right on
the money
it didn't feel good but um i've gone
through like lows and highs and we have
i don't know we we have
withstood the test of time um because a
lot of shows have come and gone but like
i i've changed as a person it is my baby
you know things that i cringe at
um
that i did on the show you know back in
the early seasons i just wasn't
comfortable
i've grown up on the show myself
so i love that it is my baby and someone
told me recently
i'm the only host of the show because
it's it's worldwide it's in many
countries
i'm the only
host that is the original host still
hosting so you know chenbot is like the
energizer bunny of big brother
you know and it's so funny because
people say chen bop but chenbot was
actually perfect for if you're reporting
on news from the white house or if
you're reporting on something going on
you know it's like that was the news
part of you well that's old school news
you know today
right right people bring their own
opinion
to the table which is not the way i
went to journalism school to learn how
to do it but i digress
um yeah chanbot that's why i was the
chenbot because like i didn't want to
show favoritism i didn't want to show my
opinion i was just there to drive this
train and be the conductor and get from
point a to b and c and d you know
and that was it and it made me laugh so
hard when someone came up with that name
i was like a robot it was just like
but first but first but first but first
but first so
i deserved it
all right um what is there anything you
what do you like most about this new
house what i like most about the new
house is the new characters you know i
love seeing people develop because like
opening night i go in and i have my
opinion on everyone and i love to be
proved wrong it's like
boy that person really sold themselves
as x but they're really why and then
you know and i and i love and i love
seeing the showmances but what i love
even more is after it's all said and
done
finding out people got married and are
raising families
we haven't had one divorce we've had so
many successful marriages come out of
big brother because think about it when
you live with someone
for you know in this pressure cooker
condition for three months
you are always together
you're gonna see their best and their
worst and you know what you're in for
and you will have gone through something
that is so unique to the two of you
that is the glue that holds these
couples together i think
no surprises
here's my question julie would you ever
is there a chance that you will ever go
in the house would you ever do it try it
for a celebrity version of it and try it
is there any shot no i mean maybe maybe
like a dozen years ago
i know julie wants to win and she's
expecting it we can't let her win
sabotage
if she wins
[Music]
you know me i'm a team player
four of us have formed an alliance me
sarah leah and holly
oh yeah we're gonna bring her down
but like as i was talking about these
challenges are so hard now
i don't know if i could physically take
the challenges i don't know i don't know
how i would do
so and you know i'm a straight shooter i
i cannot
you know it's not in my nature to lie
and i think you need at least a little
bit of that to get far in this game so
i'm not cut out for it and no in no way
this year three of doing the show while
you know in the pandemic style um what
changes this year
you know i'm sorry to say that we still
won't have a live audience um you know
so that that's a bummer
you know for better or worse i mean we
were the first show that went on
during the
pandemic the beginning of the pandemic
we were kind of like a guinea pig test
run model to see how other shows were
going to get back into production so
it's you know constant testing constant
staying in your own pods
and if you think about it when we
started 24 years ago
big brother was kind of made for
quarantine it is a show where people are
in quarantine right
once you
clear all the tests and you're in the
house
you're locked off from diseases outside
world everything so it was
the timing worked out well for us also
what does it feel like being one of the
powerhouses of the summer because now
the challenge will follow you guys right
they will they will ride your wave yeah
i mean it's very flattering you know to
still be here and to be the lead-in for
new shows to launch
and to help promote
i love that the challenge has a bunch of
big brother house guests from seasons
past many from the cookout and people
from survivor that you love and know an
amazing race it's
it is very flattering 28 cbs reality
titans are ready to compete and one
ultimate showdown
big brother there's no backdooring if
you get thrown in you gotta win i'm up
for the challenge i can win this game
can you break down one more time how
this first eviction will be the craziest
one we've ever seen the first eviction
show is not going to be traditional
and
who ends up going
won't
be it will be a surprise i'll just put
it that way
it won't necessarily be
who you think is in
either person who is in danger
i may have said too much
[Music]